trois crimes commis en loir-et-cher vont
être rejugés à partir d'aujourd'hui par
la cour d'assises d'appel d'indre et
loire
il sera notamment question de cet
automobiliste orléanais qui avait foncé
sur des gendarmes en intervention 1er
juillet 2015 sur l'autoroute a10 à
hauteur de mer la cour reviendra
également sur le double homicide de la
ferté imbault en 2015 un jeune homme
avait tué son ex-petite amie et la mère
de cette dernière à coups de hache et de
couteaux
enfin les jurés devront se pencher sur
le cas d'une épouse qui aurait tué son
mari avant de jeter son corps dans la
loire des faits qui ont eu lieu à blois
en janvier 2013 pour tous ces procès
aucune caméra ni aucune photo n'est
toléré durant les débats
c'est là qu'interviennent les croquis
d'audience ses dessins réalisés par des
illustrateurs judiciaire rencontre avec
l'un d'entre eux l'un d'entre eux pardon
il s'appelle philippe de l'or son
portrait par lucas chopin ce sont des
artistes pas comme les autres leurs
dessins font souvent la une des journaux
et pour cause ils dépeignent ce que l'on
ne peut pas photographier philippe de
l'or et dessinateur d'audience il
représente ce qu'il observe lors des
procès des tribunaux de blois et de
tours
son atelier regorge de 10 and archives
de ses oeuvres c'est un petit peu un
reportage en fait l'illustration elle
vient en complément du texte du
journaliste
elle ne doit pas être redondant tu mais
c'est pour éclairer un petit peu le
l'article pour attirer l'oeil bien sûr
aussi j'essaie de faire l'ensemble des
des personnages ce que c'est un peu une
scène de théâtre qui viennent et qui
s'exprime
au tribunal avait décidé dupond moretti
il avait fait la une de la nouvelle
république
philippe de l'or n'est pas un
journaliste mais il tente de reproduire
fidèlement ses modèles d'un jour
alors on me dirait qu'elle a un peu
caricaturé mais en fait pas tellement
pas tant que ça alors faut essayer sans
trop forcer mais essayez de faire
ressortir par le dessin la psychologie
du personnage et c'est vrai que le
dessin par rapport à une photo est
intéressant parce qu'on peut forcer le
prêt depuis 2009 il a assisté à de
nombreuses audiences célèbre la sphère
de la madoff de touraine l' affaire
courjault pourtant les faits divers les
plus médiatisés ne sont pas toujours les
plus marquants les affaires - qui me
marque le plus ce sont les affaires les
plus durs ou finalement cela la misère
ordinaire qui ressort donc moi je m'
extrait un peu de cet univers là je
reste dans ma bulle concentré sur mon
dessin à 59 ans philippe de l'or prend
toujours beaucoup de plaisir à
travailler dans les tribunaux pas
question pour le moment d'évoquer la
retraite